I want to make sure I mention this all
the demons are here this book is out
there's a large chunk at the end which
is telling you you know it's giving you
basically factual follow-ups wouldn't
you say that's true are you talking
about the end notes yeah end notes the
endnotes are just uh I put those in the
end of at the end of every book so
people can know what's real and what's
not real from all the stuff I write
about because there's historical fiction
it's historical fiction so there's real
things and if you want to know
you know did Jacob did Jake make up Viva
Knievel or is that a real movie and you
just go no Viva Knievel was a real film
and then I do the review from the 1977
daily Variety in the most daring feat of
his career Evil Knievel leaps over a
mountain of Blazing cliches and a
cavernous plot
that's so real you know what I think
that critic had made up their mind
before they went I think they went you
know to hate evil Knievel's movie I
would have written a wonderful review
for that movie uh well I think Gene
Kelly was in it well this is there was
an ERA do you remember this was it the
Swarm it was about bees Killer Bees
coming up and they got huge stars to be
in these oh the Irwin Allen all the
Irwin Island Disaster films had the
biggest Hollywood stars of the 30s and
40s and 50s were in disaster movies in
the late 70s and 80s yeah and it's
mostly them saying my God how could this
have happened think about the Towering
Inferno it had Paul Newman and Steve
McQueen and O.J Simpson and Fred Astaire
that's right keep going uh that's a fire
well Roddy McDowell's in all of them
right and George Kennedy George Kennedy
is in every almost every disaster movie
but you know so then you talked about
the Killer Bees thing in this one we've
alienated so many people on this place
about the Swarm yeah not the Swarm but
the Killer Bees so when so in the 70s
this was a legitimate fear who's old
enough to only are you the only you know
you maybe you too no no I love that you
pointed to blay who's actually about 22.
Killer Bees were a big thing that were
going to kill us all so right they were
coming from South America they were
coming they did a horror movie about it
called the Swarm they did there was an
NBC did a special about it and
researching this book I found out that
it was all pretty much invented by
Rupert ronak to sell papers oh my God he
sucks in San Antonio not prepared to say
that the first the first newspaper
Cooper he bought these San Antonio
newspapers and they basically scared the
out of the country to sell papers
and the Killer Bees were a real thing
but it was you were they were it was
going to take years for them to get to
the United States and you only really it
wasn't like one one would sting you
you'd be like like a thousand would have
to sting you to kill you anyway no no it
was it was a I remember it was a again
an incredibly cheesy kooky movie about
the Killer Bees coming and taking over
towns and I remember there's at one
point I think it was Michael Caine was a
scientist in it and he said I don't do a
Michael Kane impression it'll just be
Nixon again but no but Michael Kane says
I can't believe it was the bees they've
always been our friends like
I like of all the of all the insects it
was the bees it's more like um I can't
believe
it was the Beast it was the bees you
know it's just a slow it's a slow I'm
really shocked but it's not I can't
believe okay but there you go it was the
Beats they took a turn well well
I'll try again there you go okay there
it is there it is I love bees Mary
Poppins all right all right fool do you
remember do you remember that when I'm
the voice of reason here
then uh the has hit the fan do you
remember when uh do you remember the
horror movie starring Michael King
called the hand I just watched that did
you watch really I haven't seen that oh
I adore that movie he is a cartoonist
who loses his hand in a car accident and
then the hand starts killing people the
hand escapes and starts killing people
and then should we do the spoiler alert
or yeah I wouldn't worry if you're not
sure whether it's is it is imagining it
or it's manifesting he's like is he
killing is he killing people yeah and
he's imagining that it's his hand
creeping along I'm gonna say no I'm
going for it's actually the hand correct
but you don't find that out to like the
last minute yeah I didn't wrote it
Oliver Stone who plays a cameo as a bum
in that movie too yeah
we um we got more time let's cover some
movies
this is what talking to you does Jake
because your books are filled with uh
all this stuff then the next thing you
know we're talking about the hand yeah
and so we might as well get the word out
on the hand yeah uh I think written and
directed by Oliver Stone yeah and that
same old story about a cartoonist who
loses his hand
1981 and the Hand of course goes out and
kills people yeah so check that out I'm
sure that's one of those movies that
when you look for it on streaming you
will not find it oh I got I got places
and check out her dark web where she has
the squishy porn
[Laughter]
high five all right uh Jake Tapper book
it's a thriller all the demons are here
look it's a book
go and read it book
no you're a New York Times best-selling
author yes it's a big deal that's a cool
thing well thank you so much you guys
are very you're very kind we're not
professional I don't know that we've
helped you in any way yeah but I think
your listeners read books I think they
do they do they're very we're trying
we're trying to weed them out
we do we have actually we're very I'm uh
we have very cool fans and very erudite
fans I believe all right Jake Tapper
thanks guys God bless you go in peace
thank you so much